Now coming to the seventh
most common misconception or allegation
against Islam that Islam subjugates the
woman by keeping her behind the wheel.
They're talking about the hijab. And
before we give the reply to this
question why Islam has asked the woman
to wear hijab let us know the history
about the various civilization. When we
read history we come to know that in the
Babylonian civilization if you see
before Islam came the women were looked
down upon they were not given their
rights they were considered subhuman
they were used for sex and pleasure.
We'll just try and know what did the
various civilization how did it treat
the woman in the Babylonian civilization
if a man murdered a woman instead of him
being put to death his wife was put to
death. Can you believe if a man murders
a woman his wife was put to death in the
Greek civilization which is known as the
great civilization though the woman
lived modestly they had a they had a
myth that there was a woman by the name
of Pandora which was the which was the
reason for all the misfortune in society
and the Greek civilization
They believed in Pandora a female which
was responsible for all the misfortune
in the society. Though the Greek society
believed in modesty but later on when
ego came they became so egoous that
prostitution started. Besides the woman
being considered as a reason for
misfortune even prostitution became
ample in the Greek civilization. When we
read the Roman civilization there in
Roman civilization taking the life of
the woman a man could take the life of
his wife no problem no punishment that
means a man could kill his wife
prostitution was common nudity was
common in Roman civilization so men
woman were used for sex and pleasure and
thrown away in the Egyptian civilization
the woman was considered as an evil and
a sign of the devil In Arab civilization
before the Quran was revealed very often
when a woman was born she was put to
death. So after the Quran was revealed
after Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam who was one of the major
benefactor of the woman after the Quran
was revealed Islam gave equal status to
man and woman are equal but not
identical. And I've given a full talk on
this issue women's rights in Islam that
men and women are equal but they aren't
identical. full talk you can refer to
that. So when Islam uplifted the woman,
Islam also showed a way how the woman
should maintain her modesty. Before
talking about the modesty for the woman,
Quran first speaks about the modesty for
the man and then for the woman. The
Quran says in surah N chapter number 24
verse number 30, say to the believing
man that he should lower his gear and
guard his modesty. Say to the believing
man that he should lower his gate and
guard his modesty. That means whenever a
man looks at a woman and if any
unashamed thought comes he should lower
his case. Once there was a Muslim
brother who was staring at a girl for a
long time. I said brother what are you
doing? It's not allowed in Islam. It's
haram. So he told me that a beloved
prophet said the first glance is
permitted. The second is prohibited. I
have not completed half my glance. What
did the prophet mean when he said the
first glance is permitted the second is
prohibited. That does that means that
accidentally if you look at a woman do
not look at her again to feast on a
beauty. That does not mean you can look
at a woman for 10 minutes without
blinking and saying I have not completed
my glance. The next verse speaks about
the hijab for the woman. Allah says in
surah nur chapter number 24 verse number
31. Say to the believing man that he
should lower his gaze and guard his
modesty. And dis and say to the
believing woman that she should lower
her gaze and guard her modesty. And
display not her beauty except what
appears ordinary of and draw her head
covering over the bosom. and display not
a beauty except to a husband, to her
father, to the husband's father, to the
son, and a long list of maram who she
cannot marry is given.